i mean speaking about the rest of the
world healing
um it's it's getting to the point now
where i kind of meet a lot of people
that are planning their journeys home
and that includes us as well
i mean at least yeah you two are and uh
yeah i'm uh you know what
you know i was missing the other day and
i i know i must be [ __ ] mental
what i was missing a pub i'm just like
what's wrong with that pups are great i
mean
i've talked about how i've talked about
there's no [ __ ] i mean
i've talked about how i like pubs are
like [ __ ] idiots so like just
isn't like crosstalk and god thinks the
architecture here is great you know i
mean
god is a fake british person maybe yeah
he's ty
yeah i'm an honorary britannian
i just had this overwhelming like urge
to go to a [ __ ] weather spoons and
i'm just like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me wow
every week you should get that urge yeah
moment friday takes over you're like
[ __ ] i wanna i want the curry club
and a pint it's great you can get like a
curry a whole curry meal
and uh a full pint of your alcohol of
choice
like 10 bucks damn and then friday's
pretty good it's fish and chips fridays
as well
no you know what it is
now you're speaking my language yeah
yeah i don't know like i'm like now that
we are in the process of being able to
go back to our countries it's just like
it's
it feels good and it feels like i i get
to like kind of look forward to all the
things that have made me feel
kind of homesick i think because i
didn't think i would feel too homesick
about england
until kind of moved out of it and
couldn't go back for a while
i think i think this like lockdown or
pandemic is definitely proven to people
that like oh
maybe i am homesick just give me enough
time
i thought you're homesick first year i
was like ah it's all right it's not that
bad
yeah i was like well okay like i can get
used to this yeah and then now i'm just
like going insane now i'm like
nothing is open i can't [ __ ] do
anything you can't film any cool videos
all the time every single every single
thing is like boring
[ __ ] yeah and then now now i can't i
don't know like so we're
booking our trip home i don't even know
what the [ __ ] is happening
because every country keeps changing its
mind on what's what's happening yeah
i'm like wait do i book the hotel for a
lot for like how many days does it lock
down like well we might get rid of it
it's like
are you are you getting rid of it like
you tell me if you're getting rid of it
i would like to know right yeah so it's
really difficult right isn't it isn't
that like home quarantine an option
though
yeah yeah in the uk yeah in the uk hotel
uh and then japan might be doing uh is
doing vaccine passports
yeah i think that's to return japan yeah
to return to to return which apparently
you can apply from from the 26th my
birthday
yeah which is when we do the ultimate
birthdays
as well yeah um so yeah i don't know
what's happening i guess i'll figure it
out what's what's the first thing you're
going to do when you go back to england
yeah that's what i was going to ask as
well yeah
i i i'm go i'm going to go i'm going
straight to the [ __ ] pub
check into the hotel i guess i mean
that's the practical answer
yeah yeah but after that after you've
settled down at the hotel room what's
the first thing you want to go to
tesco's yeah tesco's actually i want a
[ __ ] meal deal
they'll probably have one of the
airports i'll probably get a meal deal
at the airport tesco's meal deal
banging yeah three pound [ __ ] dude
choice of my favorite sandwich
yeah but if it's the airport it's
probably like seven pound right i guess
that's like four yeah
it's just gonna be so weird going to
like a shop or just a tesco's
i genuinely miss airports i miss going
to an airport
i miss i was chilling at the airport
i get that you get to watch so much [ __ ]
when you're on a flight flight yeah yeah
i've been able to watch tv in so long
because i haven't been on a flight like
you know what i mean
you get so much watching done when
you're playing sure you know i'm
chilling in the lobby i mean having a
coffee
like when you're when you finally you've
checked in your bags are in the thing
it's
actually kind of chill like that that
like hour before your flight i like the
feeling
like i like the feeling of going on a
long-haul flight just knowing because it
kind of like
aside from like the long-haul part of
the flight i just like the feeling of
knowing it feels like i'm going on a
holiday you know
it feels like i'm going away for a while
and it's
there's something about going to to the
airport of like your home country
it just it just feels like it just feels
feels like you know
mum's cooking or something like that it
just feels i don't know it just there's
something about it
because every time i go visit thailand
and i step out and i see like
the thai airport i'm just like i'm
getting all nostalgic
it's just the [ __ ] airport